[Applause]
before
video begins very exciting announcement
today opera gx
i've been using this browser for i feel
like a year now
coming up at least i love this browser
i'm so glad they reach out to me
some of you already notice i use it
because they're like i heard it that's
the sounds so this is an internet
browser that focuses on gaming
it has a ton of really useful
integrations like
whatsapp it's got discord integration
instagram
twitter just really nice quick easy
access it also has a gx player which
lets you connect your apple music
spotify so you can play music easily in
your browser and for you gamers out
there the gx control which has a ram
limiter
and cpu limiter to make sure it doesn't
lag when you're playing games or
listening to music
or if you're special like my wife marcia
who likes to keep a million tabs open
and don't close them you can easily
monitor them
and keep them running another reason i
really like this browser is
the design and the customizability i'm
using these
japanese wallpapers nice looking uh
themes
as someone that's been using this
browser for a while i can actually tell
that they are
listening to feedback and constantly
caring about improving it which is
actually really cool this is small but
they have this background music
which is really nice and it's dynamic
too so if i start typing like
it changes
it's kind of cool i don't know i like it
this has just become my default browser
at this point and it's super easy to
switch over you can import all your
bookmarks in a second oh i love this
feature as well a pop-out bin
window if you're gaming in one window
and you want to watch a youtube video
you can just move it out
super useful they also have a version
for
opera gx on the phone i use this as well
i was honestly a bit skeptic when i
first heard about a gaming browser but
i downloaded it i've been using it and i
love it it's great it's free
download it and if you use the special
link in the description you'll be
greeted by a cool pewdiepie
theme background thing hey you get the
pewdiepie wallpaper let's go
i why have i not done that oh this is
way better than japan thank your opera
dx for sponsoring this video
check them out on with the video morning
again
welcome to my ugly world give me my
shader back
please at least my automatic sorting
system
beautiful beautiful as always
always work how you doing dark sven
let me put you back on your spot
darksven today
we're finding the goddamn axolotl
after about a billion memes saying i
walk right past
one in the light it's dark sun you're
not helping your ass stuck
your ass stuck in ass come on dark sven
don't do this to me
don't do this to me ducks then
thank you say you guard guard castle
what is that you were supposed to guard
this doesn't give me pleasure
[Music]
it just gives me joy
your bad influence on me alright so i
know where to go
i know where to go to get the actual
oh i'm getting it what does axolotls eat
i look this up they eat tropical fish i
forgot i think i have some
there you are tropical fish thank you
did i make a fish farm i think i did i
don't think i showed it but whatever
i did i don't i don't remember how it
worked
it works it's a fish farm somehow
what was i doing bada boom
[Applause]
just give me the axle give it to me
it's got to be a pink one too i don't
want a brown one for
they don't look good that's the only
reason don't quote me
why is making youtube videos a lot why
did i not put
soil so soul soil here
it's the only corridor i didn't put it
in
i ain't doing it now that's way too much
work i don't know what the [ __ ] was
wrong with
me when i played minecraft before
oh my gosh i gotta work forever oh gosh
i dropped all my
trash oh no i'm picking oh anything
oh uh ah i'm too rich get it away
get it away from me i don't want this
for four people stuff
get away there you go all right
so it was in here that people observed
if you see it says footsteps on the
bottom right people observed it said
mudkip
chair mudkip that's not what they're
called what did i call it that
they look like mud kick was it here are
you a mudkip
are you a mudkip are you mudkip
where is mudkip are you a mudkip
is a mudkip in here i love this update
this is so much different like
look at this you know when people make
changes
or usually when i make changes people
always complain
like i like it 20 weeks before but i
really feel like that with
how they change the ore why did they
why if it ain't broke freedom fixie
is it me or did i lose all my minecraft
brain cells like
what how do i even play this game what
kip
oh found it found the mud kit oh it's so
cute
can't wait to hug it
oh i was maiming and i found it i found
it i found the mudkip your mind
your mind kill it kill the other mudkip
dang it don't die it's a pink one
it's a really rare one mate dude we're
gonna be best friends
ow oh don't kill me don't kill me i just
want the mud tip there you go
yes there you are he's just chilling
having a bath having a good time
man there's so many zombies and i ain't
dying
for a mudkip all right oh my gosh
watch this
you better watch out ali a see that 360.
homie homie's just vibing it's an orange
mudkip you're so cute
you're so fun bro mate we got to get out
of here
we gotta skin that look at you
why are you here out of all places
you're in the worst spot
get out why am i i don't need this why
am i minding stuff i'm trying to
clear the space did i hit the mud kit
no okay how do i make mud kibble here
tropical fish i read about this oh my
god he doesn't need the tropical fish
what's your problem oh my god they keep
spawning
oh sorry everyone stop
he's following me oh he's so pathetic
and slow
oh my god i love him
oh you're so s extremely slow you're
like a sloth
how do i bring you home i didn't bring a
leash i didn't bring anything i just
wanted this stupid tropical fake that is
what
gay is it hey that's it
[Applause]
yeah i got your attention now didn't
that
eat it do i have a bucket hold up
oh he's coming i have a bucket
i got a bucket of milk he wants him
maybe he drinks milk
what is axolotl
[Applause]
[Music]
you catch them in a bucket that's right
that's right in my pocket
[Music]
ah bro i'm so strong
that i felt nothing i need another one
so i can make army
oh [ __ ] i need to find another axle dang
it
all right that's all right mike i'll
find another walmart
okay they spawn in water um
yeah more water
ah nearly died no problem
we see exit there it is
i just want to look at you there's one
little oh lookie
i want to look at you look at you
mine
your mind okay found one i got another
one
they make babies they make babies and
we train their babies we give the babies
weaponry baby arcs a lot of armory with
weaponry very strong
give plus one buff strong plus
two strength it becomes strong
and baby armor strong i know there's one
person that understand what i means
the hell is he doing
okay
no he's so toasty i didn't think this
through at all
ah why did i do that i'm an idiot
i don't have one and another push-up
push and push him push him
oh god oh god he's toasting up he's
coming to become salad manner jeff bezos
is gonna eat him
stop it stop dying you dummy
oh god don't die don't worry don't worry
there's water in the other
oh just go with me you slow stinky smell
oh god he's smelling roasted
oh i only had you for a couple minutes
why did i do these
oh that's so dumb why stop
walk the other way i don't have exo out
in my bucket
don't go through there
why is there a hole here come back come
back please come back
just come back you're gonna die you
don't want to be stay toasty my friend
come on
come on come on no don't go through the
hole
don't go through the whole you don't go
near me
and my next law i made it around me i
will murder you
i will murder you run axolotl come back
this is not a cat flap
oh my god you're so dead
and done why are you walking come back
yes it comes to come to come see
come see comes to come see i can't put
you in the bucket mate why did i tell
you
i said come back come out
yes that's my little that's my little
and
it's so blocky there we go you're out
you're free you're free
yes dude there's so much water on my
plate yes he's blue
oh where is he
man give me proper scare there
dude get in the water get a bottle of
water
come on come on come on come on come on
come on let's get out jump
jump jump jump jump jump
jump jump do it do it again come on man
come on come on
yeah you're free to round this round
you're so fast and beautiful got a good
name tag
engemar angry
the excellent sorry dark sven get out of
my way you're not important as
anger where'd he go
where is he oh that little
trippy snake war my man
staring at the wall hey anger
you know you have a lot of freedom too
hey
[Music]
all right listen up i'm gonna find you a
girl maybe you are a girl i don't know
and make baby okay don't go anywhere
anymore
we're gonna make army army's so strong
stronger bts army
that's impossible so there are
updates and i was right i was just doing
it wrong
as always if you have already loaded in
a chunk
the new update areas will not be loaded
so i have to go somewhere
i haven't gone and i think around here i
found some new stuff
i was looking offline okay
assuming that i haven't been here before
if i dig down there should be some
differences
oh there's my bedrock just like i
ordered it
oh hear water that means it can be
axolotly
curtis where's my axolotl
where's my axle model
hey all right don't need it whatsoever
but you know it's not
what huh
huh i have never found this like what
600 hours in this game i've never
found this are you serious get out of
here
no way skidaddle
whoa why did i mine it
is that rare yeah it's rare
i don't want it though i want axel at
all
[Music]
it's fine just kill me i don't care i
want axolotl
it's so dumb
[Music]
was that the axolotl sound what the [ __ ]
again
what they definitely made it less rare
axolotl where axolotl where
oh gosh that's actually this is a
spawner this could be a spawner
yeah it is how do i find like all these
rare stuff
but not a goddamn axle model
i have that oh golden apple yummy
oh oh water
axolotl come to me
don't be scared oh
what stop it minecraft you're just
weirding me out with this update
oh my god let's just
[Music]
i'm grabbing the block yeah it's mine
okay you see this new
it's new this is what i was talking
about
what is this
they drop rooney oh that's so good for
traps and stuff
oh that's gonna be sick did they hurt me
ow i think it is hurting me but i'm too
strong it's too tiny mate
yeah give me these oh i'm going to have
to do a drop test with these
what is this exactly drip stone
oh oh
it's not even worth going down that's
how rich i am i hope you understand
oh that's different okay now we're
speaking languages
you can make the water go down there
yeah we bit elevated mate
there you go
hey copper i don't need you
but i want to give me the diamonds
just the diamond smite
whatever
okay this is kind of cool i kind of wish
there was more but i'll take it yeah
look drip dripper so can we build them
then
yeah cool
[Music]
close it's all happening
it's all happening at one spot okay
first of all what is this
what'd i just do go squid and pink it's
pink it's me
oh he's dying oh it can die it cannot it
can die where's the aftermath
is that the axle oh there's so many of
them
they are attacking the script
okay what is this what is that let me
get my
smooth baby
[Applause]
i can't harvest okay where's the chloe
squid
so they maybe they spawn in caves okay
i'm sorry mate you go
hang on back there you go what do you
drop glowing sound
we're finding all this stuff
very exciting hell yeah
i did see another axolotl and yes i am
going to get it
thank god for uh ender chests and what
is these
don't hurt me i come for the axolotl
there you are oh gosh he's swimming away
got him i got him i'm dying got him
got him get him got him get it
another one oh god
that's all right yeah let's get some
more squidding
that's actually cool i like these
they're very pretty nope your sack will
be mine
is that a ton of axolotls no that's
vicious stupid fish
stupid you're dumb cool okay very
exciting
maybe not so disappointment after all
hello i wanted to set this off
no really you're gonna be like that all
right
oh yes excellent good day
you're very cute and beautiful and
therefore you die
whoa that's huge mate
[Music]
huge bp oh they keep spawning here nice
damn so many
don't run don't be scared another i saw
another one
they keep spawning here
[Music]
oh i'm so rich from you guys thank you
oh gosh okay yes i found another thing
i already got one of these but i don't
know what it is but i want it
deep sling looks kind of cool
what'd it do though i think i'm good on
axolotls i i don't need that
we're good i'm gonna breed them oh but
they
said no i have to get it i have to get
it
[Applause]
drink the milk sure
there you are you're so pretty
[Applause]
come on yes all right we're done i'm
going home
i brought you a little gift of rooney
where is he there he is he loves the
corners
oh there's so cute together
yes oh there's so many of them
and we're still toasty from the nether i
love it
oh yes so many envers
okay now breed how do i make them breed
army army you need a bucket
of tropical fish ah damn it
i gotta see i gotta see a baby excellent
i gotta see it
i know where i know where i can get them
i just don't remember how to get there
oh god
it's not there i think it's here
uh
oh look is that chicken i left here for
some reason
okay here we go i need bucket bucket
you're telling me i've never done this
okay
all right good enough so now that we
have the glowing sac
basically that you can make signs with
text that glows
and i definitely need to make signs so i
will do it
it's not the most amazing thing in the
world but it's a nice addition and i'll
take it
ax a little baby though a bit we'd be
more interesting in it
pretty chuffed at the minute my sorry
i know it's cringy i can't stop there we
go
legendary moment okay make sure envar
gets one
where are you oh there we go yeah and
then you
and then you you make babe come on
let me see the baby
so look
at you you're so small
are they mine like are they like sheep
they go where they please or
i don't know i'm just happy they're here
that's a cool addition well done eng
mario you keep staring in wall you do
great job
oh oh he's trying to go up but he's too
dumb
oh poor thing hold up let me try the
sign really quick i don't see how it
looks like
dark sven you cannot believe the
adventures today
thank you dark seven
roams here and you just add maybe
whoa what that looks great
i like it yeah that's cool okay
mojang you get the pass
who said that oh my gosh
why are they so broken
hole up this is perfect
i have a go yeah you can hurt me all you
want i don't care i have any fencing
follow me my dude we gotta do the drop
test i forgot
you're gonna be part of a science
experiment have fun
follow me don't be scared we're just
gonna see how much pain you can endure
sounds good okay cool so you stay here
and don't what the hell is he holding a
cactus what's wrong with you
looks like a cucumber right okay
oh my god where do you come
removed my llama idiot
okay drop test one
drop a rooney
[Music]
drop it it killed him
he died maybe you have to do like this
oh okay drop test two
don't be scared all right you're brave
[Music]
no that's awesome
okay that's it for this episode special
giveaway about my minecraft videos
beautiful see in the next one brofist